couple things about money that I think
I'm very curious about there's obviously
how much total you made I'm curious
about yeah I made I requested a million
dollars a year or no just total okay so
that's total so you hit a million that
and that means you have a million cash
or that means you're spending as you're
making uh that included The Re-Up that
included The Re-Up but The Re-Up was
only
um
rehab was wasn't more like 150 000 okay
because you know I'm paying I'm getting
the ticket I'm getting it for the low
yeah so I'm really only have to bring
the Mexicans 100 100 000 if I'm buying
50 joints this is two a pop more or less
yeah right in the summertime it's gonna
be a little higher when Supply is lower
but you know so yeah a lot of that is
just [__] cash so you're sitting on a
million at one point what is your get
out number in your head yes dude it
started out with a hundred thousand
dollars I'm like God 250. I feel that
[__] about stand up
Yeah the more you make the more yeah
yeah yeah but but your overhead is way
lower than in this [__] you know what I
mean so it's like dude I mean there's no
taxes uh people are working for me for
peanuts this is during the recession so
I got nice college educated white dudes
women even making that drive down there
for me muelling my [__] back for like a
hundred dollars a joint but to them it's
like five grand just to do this is big
money you know like I'm gonna do that
I'm hurting so but it's just insane so a
hundred thousand was like my get out
number then it went up to 250 and I was
like yo I looked at the forecast and I
was like okay we're gonna be at a
million in no time let's just do that
right but then I had this opportunity to
go into business down in Columbia I mean
I had a lot of business opportunities
but the get out plan was going to be
this real estate deal I was going to do
in Colombia so I was and that was going
to cost me about four or five hundred
grand so I'm like I gotta get I gotta
make that back like I'm gonna invest
that but I want to be 1.5 so you can do
that deal I want to be a million liquid
plus whatever I have in assets yeah you
know what I mean
I remember you saying you're like a few
months away or something yeah okay so
where are you hiding the money you're
not just keeping a million dollars cash
in one place uh you know I had [__] my
parents addict had it in the garden safe
deposited digging bro digging I'm
Mexican now
I am the Mexican now you know you're
digging you're putting it in the garden
yeah you have so much of folks Place
yeah your folks Savvy to it a little bit
or not just not to this level now they
knew throughout the years I'd be home
from college and my mom would be like
hey I was cleaning your room and I found
like 50 000 in cash in your backpack so
you're gonna have to you can't stay here
we know you're back dealing drugs you
know but we'll still pay for college
okay you can't stay here for the summer
time
it's about them they don't want their
kid to not go to college of course yeah
of course and the embarrassment too like
that yeah that's the worst part like yes
he sells the drugs but he got a batches
also though like and this is no knock on
like the black community or or any like
lower class communities it almost makes
drugs
drug dealer though
hear me out
comfortable with casual races that's
like for to be from Portland and then be
like yeah the blacks are like this in
prison I'm just dying from casual
yeah this is professional racism I'm
saying if you're if you're from a family
of entrenched drug dealers I'm not
saying say you're from Harlem and your
uncle's been locked up and your [__]
grandfather was locked up this is the
family business and you get locked up
it's horrible it doesn't make the pain
any less but it's just a little more
normalized so like the embarrassment
that a family that's not used to
incarceration feels is enough for me to
never do it again
and dude and like W.E.B DuBois talked
about that he's like that's the or his
counterpart whatever the other dude was
that's what he said he was like uh that
embarrassment that expectation that
white people have is kind of what keeps
them in school on the straight narrow
you know what I mean I knew I was
talking to a guy that got locked up he's
did like 10 years for selling drugs in
Boston he said when he got locked up
when he first walked into the prison it
was as if it was like college
orientation and you were like a
sophomore and you saw a freshman from
your school come in they were all like
dude we're waiting for you yeah
it was just like the guys on their block
and he was like oh yeah welcome to the
crew like this is where we sit this is
where we eat we're all waiting for you
you got a seat for you yeah literally
they were like we knew you're gonna be
here yeah yeah so that's that's kind of
what I mean by that yeah my parents were
embarrassed I did this
the expectation is everything the
expectation is huge because even with
the Sweden thing happened even though I
really didn't do something bad to get in
that situation the biggest thing I felt
was guilt that I disappointed my mom
yeah
she did something wrong in raising you
yeah she busted her ass so I gave you
all the opportunities yeah yes I'm doing
fine
I was the man in there though I was a
cool American
you were their black friend yeah so so
the money's held in your parents like
that I gotta say if deposit boxes
everywhere okay um connected to Banks
don't do that don't don't do that
obviously connected to your name like an
LLC yeah what's the best way to flip it
like you obviously see the breaking bad
[__] where they're you know like do you
think about starting a business listen I
was very young I was 22 23 when this all
started to pop off so I was just started
and that's really what began like my
financial literacy was because I would I
would buy like Rich Dad Poor Dad how to
invest I was reading Warren Buffett Dave
Ramsey yeah counting my drug money while
I was reading uh you know yeah [__]
Mark Cuban's books right yeah and uh I
should have started flipping it from the
beginning from my first 50 000.
how do you make it clean can you talk
about the gifts I would go by and I do a
whole episode on this episode five you
gotta launder your money okay they're
monetizing it still on YouTube crazy
so I I would start buying sneakers okay
I had 50 Grand just to move I would pay
some kids to go stand out at that
Supreme store okay right and and buy 50
Grand worth of sneakers and then we just
go put those shits online and sell them
even if you take a loss
10 grand loss you sell them for you just
change your money for ten percent bro
it's less than tax explain to people
explain to people what uh it usually
costs to clean money because you can get
it professionally yeah yeah I wondered
but what did they take and they're
taking like a third I don't know I have
no idea you know like a Scarface is like
the they were talking about like 30 all
right let me do three points on your
money yeah whatever but I actually have
no idea that's the highest level and
even there like that's a way to get
yourself caught because you've got a guy
putting you know millions of dollars
into a shell company it's all traceable
still right when you take cash and buy
oh he's gonna get clipped of course he's
gonna talk about your ass that's the
first person they go after because the
financial crimes are easier to to I
guess
um there's more evidence there's more
proof of these friends always a paper
trail yeah but but if I'm because we
want it low-key because we want to make
sure that we know where our [__]
money of course
yeah yeah that's the only thing that you
can't relinquish any trust you know or
like any responsibility it's like I need
to know exactly where the bank account
is I don't even know where the yeah yeah
and because of that there's no
separation there's no barrier dude I
talked to I talked to Roger Reeves he
was Pablo Escobar's number one cocaine
pilot him and Barry seal I had him on my
podcast he had like 50 million in Cayman
Island bank accounts and they they went
and you know all of it I'm like that's
not going to be me that's not going to
be I'd rather make 5 million bucks and
just launder it over 10 years 40 50
Grand at a time yeah because if I'm the
IRS I could conceivably come to you
Andrew and be like where did you get the
money to buy uh 100 pairs of sneakers
yeah but you just get lost there's no
way it's just too if you're paying your
taxes though exactly you can pay them
off right away you so you have bills of
sales the only thing you don't have is
bills of purchases right bills of sales
so when you were the sneakers right you
don't have proof of making the money yes
exactly well they look at that kind of
[__] at a low enough level 100
000 I don't think so when you ping it
around enough and then you immediately
take that 40 Grand and you put it into
some real estate yeah right you're just
making it inconvenient to track down of
course make it hard as hard for them if
they're getting their pound of Flesh why
would they even look into you correct
correct right I'm almost like if I'm the
IRS I'm like you're paying extra 33 or
40 like exactly like you it's like you
tell on yourself first yeah it's like
you've got you I'm paying you I come to
you I'm not waiting for you to come to
me
immediately yeah exactly he also said
there's the simplest things I learned
from watching your [__] and
whatever
um the gift situation yeah you can give
a gift up to what 16 yeah and I didn't
know this I actually did not know the
Shawshank [__] uh what's that the scene
of Shawshank you can gift your you can
gift your wife up to 10 grand remember
he tells the the CEO that yeah
tells the CEO that he tells the CEO that
you could gift your wife up to yeah he
goes do you love your wife
dangling them over the building yeah
that's what he starts doing all the
taxes okay so break down the gift so now
it's up to like what did I say on the
episode 16
000 I had to research that because I
know I did not know that back then
somebody if I'm your mom I can gift you
just give you sixteen thousand dollars
don't have to declare it on my end yeah
and it's tax-free on your end yeah so
and actually I did that a few times like
because I did have an LLC open I would
just give my boys five grand each here
let's fly to Vegas just don't burn it
all in the chips and then give me the
receipts and we go cash out and then we
go put that back all right don't burn it
on the chips
buy bread and chips yeah you know lose
2500 of it and then we'll go and then
exactly and then give me the bill of
sale thank you so on a low level you can
have 10 friends give you a gift every
year exactly 160 000 use laundered
exactly as opposed to hey I'll cut you a
check for 16 000. you give to me sixteen
thousand and now you're allowed to
receive infinite gifts yeah correct
tax-free correct There's No Limit
there's no one per year so you have to
basically give them money so that they
can give you the gift correct now
correct now if you're tied into a big if
you have a big Federal Rico indictment
yeah they're going to come they're going
to come lean on those people right but
you know I give advice to like middle
class I'm making a million a year yeah
drug dealers yeah that's the way you do
it is you get the [__] out of the game
yeah you know is there a game now with
like weed being legal Pharmaceuticals
being so dope yeah I almost feel like
like I almost feel like all drugs are
getting squeezed out like I mean that
for real like yeah yeah it's sad like
Pharmacy it's sad it's sad there was a
good back in my day
it was coke Heron and weed it was CBS
NBC yeah ABC it was a simpler times now
it's a goofy ship yeah but it's it's
goofy [__] but it's almost like more
safe it's like you could get a similar
high from your parents [__] uh what's
called medicine cabinet right without
the risk of having something illegal on
you the weed you're just getting from
the store yeah so I'm like
yeah being a drug dealer now nah but the
drug dealers are they're into the pills
too they're like oh so they're basically
getting the pills and then flipping the
pills so people got you yeah and I I
guess drug dealers are selling perks and
yeah
what do you get I don't know I don't
know it was never my game I never liked
small change I never liked small change
items I've also I've heard that like
weed has actually become more popular
for like small drug dealers now that
it's been legalized actually that's true
why is that because the taxes 80 or 75
of the the uh marijuana Market in
California is still illegal still in the
black market so that makes sense because
if you decriminalize it now I don't have
any risk in buying it from a drug dealer
and if I'm a drug dealer I don't have
any risk in selling it because
decriminalize and if it's that much
cheaper these dumb [__] tax
weed yeah it's a more drug dealers again
yeah more people are smoking weed on top
of that so like if I'm a kid that's like
oh I don't want to smoke a weed but now
I'm like oh I love
yeah it's better for the consumer it's
worse for the dealer because everybody's
dealing now too so yeah there's crazy
back in my day I took that risk
knowingly because nobody else wanted to
take it anymore or less and that's where
that that Vig that fee came in you know
yeah now everybody's selling it the only
way to really get rich is an American
drug dealer is to have huge grows huge
and then sell it wholesale to a bunch of
dispensers so the jail was a big buried
entry that allowed you to make money
because most people are not risking jail
guys like me like there's no more
there's no more just got middlemen Pure
middlemen never touch the scale I go
take the bricks and just give them to
the next guy right right because now
because now if I'm a drug wholesaler a
dealer in Philly New York I could just
go straight to California and make a
deal with the grower himself right but
back in the day those were secret
connections because now that the Growers
are public exactly you could Google them
you call them
bro they take down these huge grows out
in the desert like Palm Springs area
greenhouses with tens of thousands of
plants they'll rate it like it's a drug
raid nobody will go to jail just write
them a ticket here you go wow are you
are you able to like suss out when
someone's playing with drug money like
like if you if you had gotten out clean
you would have had this real estate
business you would have been chilling on
like a Mill and everyone would have been
like wow this guy's just like good a
business or something or if his parents
gave him money whatever they would have
thought something about you because but
if I meet someone that has like a small
business and they're like making a bunch
money and I don't really get it I never
assume drugs I always assume like
inheritance or their genuses or Bitcoin
or some [__] yeah are you able to like
figure out like oh no this person's
playing with drugs well if they're white
I always assume it's an inheritance you
know what I mean of course it's
financially responsible you know
um no I I don't I don't I don't even
know I don't think like that right like
um if if somebody's good at legal
business it's doesn't matter how they
got their drug money because they would
have been good at this [__] regardless
you know that's interesting yeah wait
wait wait
do you really believe that yeah
yeah now now if I hear people say that
but I don't I don't I don't buy it you
don't think Jay-Z would be Jay-Z if he
didn't sell drugs he he totally would
wait what was the question just so I can
understand I don't think Jay-Z would be
Jay-Z right now if he never I think
Jay-Z happened to be a really good
businessman that also sold drugs I think
there are a lot of people who sell drugs
I think it's a much easier thing to be
profitable on because there's much less
competition right Jay-Z needed the drug
game to give him what do you mean like
Jay-Z needed to open a pizza shop it's
like 75 [__] pizza shops in New York
if you're selling cocaine it's like not
that many people are going to take that
risk sure sure so so when you have
something simple like a pizzeria like of
course having a bunch of drug money
helps you expand right away right right
um but you probably could have you could
have done that regardless would have
just taken you longer you know what I
mean I feel like selling drugs would be
helpful for international export import
businesses even if they're legit because
it's about building those relay
relationships and making sure that
there's enough of a moat around those
relationships where you can get that
product be it legal it could be [__]
olive oil but being able to connect that
person with this person over here like
what you're doing right building enough
Connections in [__] a developing
country you can see a country kind of
changing around you go oh I need to tap
into certain industries like I feel like
drug dealers would be really good at
that but once it's open market I don't
know if I could say specifically that
they could apply the same business
practices to like you really want to
compete with Bezos like there's no way
you know I mean these guys are savages
yeah well drug dealing built a lot of
America definitely go to Medellin I mean
it looks like Beverly Hills it's crazy
it's Miami culiacan Mexico dude yeah
there's no homeless people I mean Los
Angeles absolutely looks worse than
culiacan Mexico really the only legal
industry is tomatoes and and they're
Farmers you know what I mean that's how
they learn how to grow weed Goods back
in the day so but but that money
absolutely pays for Public Works [__]
you know all different kinds of things
wow but you know to your point like I
don't know I think I think good business
people would be that way regardless just
drugs gave them a boost let me put this
I think it's very possible that there
are people that are good at business and
happen to fall into drug dealing and I
think that's also possible that there
are people who aren't that good at
business but since they're dealing drugs
they're having more
successful business I think a Jay-Z is a
specific type who's like yeah whatever
he was going to do he was going to be
really good and also Jay-Z didn't take
his drug money and start Rockefeller
that was Don who is it big big [__] who
got ended up getting locked up so it
wasn't even his drug money it was just
his selling drugs that gave him a little
bit of talk about yeah yeah